[Music]
in this video we will explain what a
building consent is when you need one
and how to get one the building consent
process ensures your project complies
with the new zealand building code
building consents are required for all
sorts of buildings but here we'll we'll
focus on residential homes first of all
see if your planned project is listed as
an exemption in schedule 1 of the
Building Act there is a guidebook for
schedule 1 that lists the range of
low-risk building projects that do not
require a building consent while shed
your one building work can be done by
anyone it still needs to comply with the
building code any plumbing and drainage
work needs to be carried out by licensed
or certified people whether or not a
building consent is required the
homeowner is responsible for determining
if the work requires a building consent
as well as ensuring any work complies
with the Building Code note there may be
other rules and regulations you'll need
to comply with some common examples of
schedule 1 exemptions include a
retaining wall that retains less than
one and a half meters of ground with no
additional loading a dick that is low to
the ground a pergola that is not roofed
a fence shorter than two and a half
meters a shed smaller than ten meters
square and more than its own height away
from the boundary there's also a range
of projects relating to repairs and
maintenance
if your work isn't listed in schedule
one our building consent is required you
now need to find out if your planned
project is cast as restricted building
work restricted building work must be
designed and carried out or supervised
by a licensed building practitioner or
LBP
the LBP is responsible for ensuring
compliance with the building code
however if you are the homeowner you
could apply for an owner builder
exemption but you need to know that you
would be responsible and liable for the
work lb fees are available in five areas
of building work check that the people
you're using have the relevant licenses
on the LVP website restrictive building
work affects either the primary
structure or the water tightness of a
house the primary structure includes the
beams bracing columns foundations roof
and walls water tightness systems
protect the house from outside moisture
and include damp proofing and
waterproofing the roof and wall cladding
examples of restricted work might
include moving load-bearing walls adding
a room onto a house a complete repealing
of a house
or building a new house some work might
be classed as non-restricted building
work where you don't need an LBP to do
the work here if you do the work
yourself you will be responsible and
liable for meeting Building Code
requirements
so how do you get a building consent
first compile your application form
drawings and plans specifications
supporting documents and the deposit fee
then submit your application to Council
you can submit your application by post
or drop it off at the council office it
takes up to 20 working days to process
an application if we ask a question your
application is put on hold until we get
this information and full when you're
building consent is granted you can
start the work be sure that you or your
LBP read and understand the requirements
of the building consent your building
consumer will list the inspections
required at various stages of the
project for a new house these will range
from sites set out to cladding and
roofing through to installation
embracing please ensure your plans and
any relevant documents are available on
site and that the inspector has safe and
unobstructed access to the site if you
have applied for a building consent you
should not start the work prior to the
consent being issued if you do you could
be fined as to remove the work you've
done or be issued a notice to fix
unconsented works may make it difficult
to sell the building or to get insurance
once all site inspections are completed
and approved the final step is to apply
for the code compliance certificate this
is the final stage of your building
consent and it confirms you have carried
out as near as practically seen work
that was done in compliance with your
building consent it will go on your
council property file and will be
relevant for getting insurance or to
prospective buyers this video only gives
an outline of building consents
please check our website for more
information happy building